hello everyone and welcome to another
really wild game from the saint louis
rapid and blitz the rapid event uh it's
linear dominguez versus magnus carlsen
and before we check out the game yes i
did receive a copyright claim from my
previous video
uh the nipple versus xion game where i
showed the 10 second clip of
brave so robin by monty python but i'm
sure you'll agree it was uh
well it was uh it was definitely worth
it uh so
uh just wanted to mention that because
the video due to that is not available
in some countries so
if you're not able to watch my previous
video uh sorry about that
uh but yeah getting back to this one uh
magnus really needs to go back
uh you know get back into uh into the
tournament because he lost that game to
nepo
uh in the uh on day one due to a
disconnect uh and now
let's see how he does against dominguez
here he has the black pieces and
dominguez is white and opens with e4
so magnus goes for e5 we have knight to
f3 and magnus goes for
d6 he goes for philidor's defense uh and
here
we have d4 of course uh this is the the
main move with e captures on e4
of course not bishop to g4 you only play
bishop to g4 if you want to check
if your opponent is a morphe fan so e
captures on v4
knight captures and knight to f6 now
attacking the pawn so why the develops
while defense knight c3 and the bishop
to e7
and bishop to f4 not the the absolute
main move but it is played when
white wants to uh make haste and castle
queen side as soon as possible
so magnus castles kingside and the
dominguez goes queen to d2 prepares the
castle queen side
c6 by magnus and now castles queen side
and of course now that we have castles
on opposite sides of the board
uh it is uh of course natural that one
player attacks on the queen side and one
on the king side and is usually a race
so magnus starts immediately with b5
uh we have f3 strengthening the e4 pawn
so if you kick away the knight
you don't have to worry about losing the
e4 pawn but b4
uh just the same and now you can choose
knight e2 knight b1 or
knight to a4 all three have their merits
but knight to b1 is what the dominguez
goes for and now a5 magnus of course
uh wants the bust open the the position
on the queen side as soon as possible
uh whereas dominguez wants to do the
same on the king side so g4 h4 is coming
and he also wants to push on the king's
side
with a4 by magnus and now uh there are
games where knight to f5 was played and
also a3 is a known move in this position
however h4 uh by the means is a new move
so already as of move 12 we have a
completely new game
we have c5 by magnus now grabbing more
space on the queen side
knight to f5 and now eliminating the
knight from f5 you could just leave it
there but it is an extremely strong
piece so
magnus decides to get rid of it even
though it means uh well
sort of opening the g file so g captures
end
knight to c6 uh the knight can also come
into the game you can go knight d5 you
can you can play c for b3 and so on
so h5 dominguez continues his attack on
the king side and now
knight to d4 and this is now a monster
knight it's very hard to get rid of it
you have to play something like c3 uh
which will uh
open up your king's position but this is
uh
kind of what you have to do at some
point and here
it's most probably the most important
moment in the game whether
you play or whether not uh to play a h6
because it's a it's a really a crazy
race but it's um
i think for a rapid game it's a very
hard decision because if you play h6 and
you meet
a h6 with a3 then if we go into a race
captures captures with
czech king captures and now rook e8 yes
white also opened up the the black king
but it
is black who's attacking here uh for
example after you go queen h2
uh with ideas of maybe eliminating the
knight and then
playing queen captures on h7 it's uh
also black will be attacking queen a5
now going after the a2
pawn and there's no good way to defend
this if bishop c4 just b3
you force the bishop to capture and then
you eliminate the bishop captures
captures
and now after the bishop after the
bishop is captured and it's traded for
the knight
now you finally get queen captures on a2
and after king c3
black can trade queens however black can
also continue the attack with queen a5
uh with check and then it's uh hard to
say
who would come up on top here but
black's moves are a lot more natural and
for a rapid game i don't think this is a
good idea to go for white
so dominguez holds off with the h6 idea
he first
improves the position with queen g2 now
he has a very nice queen here then
h6 will be very strong so king the h8 by
magnus he says
okay now if you go h6 i can play g5 and
now whether captures or captures i do
have king g8 and you're not
checkmating me here uh but maybe
maybe h6 was the way to go because here
dominguez played
bishop to e3 back and now magnus says
okay you didn't play h6
you're not going to play h6 so here
magnus plays h6 himself
bishop to d3 dominguez continues
developing and now
knight to d7 and here magnus uh frees up
the f6 square for his bishop as this
bishop
pawn battery uh will be an incredible
defensive resource as you'll see later
on so rook h2 g1
uh dominguez threatens checkmate here
and now bishop to f6 defending with
f4 with ideas of e5 as you really want
to get
rid of that bishop here so rook to e8
and
now comes bishop captures on d4 uh not
not wanting to wait
for the knights to get into the game and
also to meet this
c4 move so here dominguez eliminates it
captures and now knight to d2 uh we have
knight to c5 by magnus again putting
pressure on the bishop
uh also you are you are ready to push
those pawns on the queen side
and now knight to c4 putting more
pressure here really
really preparing to push this pawn to e5
but magnus says no problem just b3 and
it's not good however you capture it for
example if a capture say captures you
just open up the rook here
and it's uh it's a really bad position
for white
so instead after this b3 move with king
to b1
uh now just uh not allowing in any quick
uh
moves with the rook so here b captures
in c to check
bishop captures and now rook to b8
aligning the rook on the same file here
if the knight moves a3 will be a
possibility
so here we have bishop to d3 e5
although it looks like a really great
move is easily met with
rook captures on e5 and of course you
still keep this bishop here
and after knight captures bishop
captures it doesn't matter that you have
two rooks a queen and the bishop
because this bishop okay let's use maybe
blue
uh this bishop and g7 pawn uh white will
not be
able to break through this even with uh
two rooks queen and the bishop
because the rooks are useless here the
queen also and the bishop is a dark
is a light square bishop uh and this is
on a dark square so
this is actually a great defensive
resource for
for magnus so after this rook to b8
movie we have bishop back to d3
uh and uh now uh here magnus goes for
rook to b4
this is maybe a bit too slow maybe uh
bringing the queen into the game uh
queen e7 queen to c7 are are some of the
the engine stop choices although this is
uh playing something like this in a
rapid game
is always hard to well uh come by so
magnus goes for the more
human rook to b4 which comes with the
obvious threat of just knife captures
here bishop captures and you lose the
knight so it's a
very nice rook there also you could
double up here maybe queen b8
however uh dominguez meets this with a3
he kicks away the rook
rogue b3 and now bishop back to c2
magnus goes back
and now dominguez goes e5 so it's not
not much different magnus will still
give up the exchange because
it's the only thing he can do so d
captures e
f captures an e5 and now rook captures
an e5 we have captures captures and now
again
uh bishop to d3 so it's hard for
for magnus to make any progress here but
it's also very hard for dominguez to
make any progress because
you're just not coming through this
bishop pawn combo
is uh just brilliant so here bishop back
to f6 by magnus and now queen to c2
putting pressure on the knight here
so queen to a5 magnus just nicely
defends it
uh we have rook to g2 once the queen
moves the rook will also help out with
the defense of the
b2 pawn uh and here magnus decides to
to give up this knight for bishop so
captures captures and now queen to d5
a very nice centralizing move by the
queen also attacking the rook on g2
so you have to do something about it and
here dominguez plays
rook to e2 and the thing about rook to
e2 is that it completely blunders the
game
but i'm not going to tell you why
because it'll spoil the fun
so i'm first going to show you what
magnus played here here magnus improved
the position with king to h7
sort of to remove any back rank
weaknesses
but now dominguez played queen to e4 but
the game is still completely lost for
dominguez due to the same reason as it
was before but i'm going to show it
after we check out the game but now feel
free to pause the video here and win the
game for magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting
this and this uh and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show yes of
course it's rook captures on b2
and now the point is if rook captures
then the queen is no longer defended so
magnus just wins the queen so there's
only one move uh
you of course you're not going to play
something like this to get check made it
so there's only one move king captures
on b2
and now comes d3 with check opening up
the
this uh dragon's diagonal i mean this
bishop has been such a
such a beautiful defensive resource and
now it becomes the the strongest
attacking piece
for magnus here which is simply
incredible and here you have to move the
king where do we go king c1 king b1
doesn't really matter
we can show if king b1 then queen b3
check
king to c1 and now you get this queen to
c3 check and now it's
just a game over king b1 and now queen
to a1 is checkmate because the bishop
the pawn covers the c2 square so instead
uh
we have king c1 by dominguez and now
queen to c5 check now it looks really
wild
because again king d2 king b1 is a
possibility but again if king
king to be one then queen b5 check king
back to c1 and now d
captures on e2 the pawn is protected and
you don't really have anything with
white anymore
rook d2 you're gonna go queen c5 check
king b1 and now finally queen g1 check
and the queen now
uh also defends the queening square
you're gonna move the king and now
another queen is brought into the game
so instead after queen to c5 we have
king to d2
but now of course comes queen to c2 with
check with
king the e1 by dominguez opening up an
attack towards carlson's queen
and here there's only one game one move
that wins the game for magnus and of
course you'll see it as it's the only
move
uh bishop to h4 with check and now the
point is
if the queen captures you no longer have
a defense against queen capture sunny 2
with checkmate
and if you move the king let's say king
to f1 or something then comes queen
captures and b1 with
check rook and block hoping to go into
some sort of a king and pawn end game
but it's uh all in vain you can just
trade into a kingdom pawn
in game and here g6 wins the game the
king component game is of course winning
for black black is up two pawns it's not
even close but
for those of you who don't believe me
captures captures captures captures and
after king d2
just king g5 captures h5 or pretty much
whatever and now the
the pass pawn and extra pawn is very
fast and winning
so after this bishop to h4 check move uh
dominguez resigned and
what a victory for for magnus carlsen uh
so
uh what i wanted to show you in that
position uh is pretty much the same
because here after bishop d3 we had this
rook before
and after a few more moves uh this
sorry i rewind a bit too much carlson
played queen to d5
check and dominguez played rook to e2
and now the same idea applies only first
you have to kick the queen away
carlson played a waning move and then
dominguez allowed this combo
but carlson could have forced it with
rook to b3 because the queen now has to
move
and after any move you still can go into
this line captures captures and check
and everything repeats itself but uh
carlson made a preparating move and then
dominguez allowed him to execute uh to
execute this but it's even
nicer with real captures on b2 rather
than forcing the queen to move and then
capturing
i guess both is nice like i don't know
uh it depends
on how you prefer your chess uh lines to
begin
uh but yeah that's the game uh round
five of the saint louis rapid
i do hope you enjoyed it and we're going
to show the standings and the standings
are
very interesting because like i said
magnus lost the game to nepo
due to a disconnect in the first day but
he still
emerged on top after day two because he
defeated uh all of uh all three of his
opponents he defeated dominguez here
he defeated level aryan and he defeated
pentala hari krishna in round six so he
just obliterated everyone on day two
and he's again leading the tournament
second place yanni pomnishi uh who lost
that game to xiong the previous one
we've shown i'm sorry if some of you
can't see it but
i mean what are you gonna do uh then
wesley saw also with eight
uh lebanon with seven pentala hari
krishna with six with five points we
have hikaru nakamura alexander grishou
and jeffrey
young uh linear dominguez in ninth place
and in 10th place again
alireza firuja uh who can't seem to to
budge
for from last place in both tournaments
but you know the tournament is still
young anything can happen
so uh that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
michael bartlett and musa alphabet juan
pablo barrera eidon bielski and
bala subramaniam mariapan for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the st louis
events checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day